Hello,
Dr Peter says,
Hey,
there we go.
That's a night.
I'd like to ask you about two different
psychological disorders.
The first being borderline personality
disorder,
so two lectures ago,
somebody asks you about it and you gave
very sparse answer.
I can't remember exactly what you said,
but it seemed like it was a of it,
there was too much complexity to just
answer it right there and then,
and then somebody else.
All Cox asked you about the same
disorder in your Patriot on live stream
recently and when they,
when they asked you that you kind of,
you kind of stopped for a moment and
something I don't know,
something kind of flicked on in your
head and it seemed like in you and you
thought for a couple seconds and then
you said,
you know what,
I don't think that I can answer that
right now because it's just too,
it's just too bloody complex.
And I was wondering,
uh,
just like,
many young men have gravitated towards
your lectures.
Do you think that there's something
about this particular disorder that a,
there's something about people with this
particular disorder that might gravitate
to your insights and your lectures?
Okay.
So now I would say probably no to the
second one,
but I could comment more about
borderline personality disorder.
I think I have enough mental energy to
do that tonight.
So technically speaking,
it's often considered the female variant
of antisocial personality disorder.
So it's,
it's,
it's classified or it's classified in
the domain of externalizing disorders,
acting out disorders,
and I think what happens,
we don't understand borderline
personality disorder very well mean.
It's characterized by tremendous
impulsivity,
radical confusion of identity and then
this pattern of idealization of,
of people with whom the person afflicted
with a disorder is associated with
radical idealization of those people and
then radical devaluation of them.
And then there's another theme that sort
of weaves along with it,
which is the proclivity of people with
borderline personality disorder to
presumed that they will be abandoned and
then to act in a manner that makes such
abandonment virtually certain.
And so it's a very complicated disorder,
but that I think gets at the crux of it.
One of the things that's interesting
about people with borderline personality
disorder and my experience is that
they're often quite intelligent and you
see in the person with borderline
personality disorder,
something like that,
the waste or the squandering of
tremendous potential,
they seem capable of thinking through
the nature of their problems and
analyzing them and discussing it,
but not capable whatsoever of
implementing any solutions.
And
technically there's no relationship
between Iq and conscientiousness.
It's very weird because if you read the
neuropsychological literature and you
read about the functions of the
prefrontal Cortex,
they're usually conceptualized in
intellectual terms and they're
associated with planning and
strategizing and so forth.
And
that's what conscientiousness is,
is planning and strategizing and
implementation.
But the correlation between Iq and
conscientiousness is zero.
And so as the correlation between
working memory and conscientiousness,
zero and zero is a very low correlation.
Right?
I mean really it's hard to find things
in psychology that are correlated at
zero.
Things tend to be correlated to some
degree.
They tend to be interrelated.
The borderline seems to be able to
strategize and to abstract,
but not to be able to implement
and
and so this,
the intellect per se seems to be
functional,
but it's not embodied in action.
It's very so it can be frustrating to be
associated with someone who has
borderline personality disorder because
they can tell you what the problem is
and even tell you what the solution
might be,
but there's no implementation.
Okay,
so maybe something went wrong
developmentally.
We don't know exactly how these sorts of
things come about.
The other thing that seems to be
characteristic of borderline people with
borderline personality disorder is that
they remind me very much of people who
are two years old and in some manner
like people with borderline personality
disorder can have temper tantrums.
In fact,
they often do and you know now and then
you see a temper tantrum and they're
usually thrown by two year olds.
Right?
Most people grow out of temper tantrums
by the time they were about three.
They're very rare at four,
which is a good thing because if they're
still there at four,
that is not a good diagnostic predictor.
That's a good diagnostic predictor,
but it's not the kind that you want and
you know,
it's funny the way that we respond to
two year old temper tantrums because the
two year old will throw themselves on
the ground and eat their hands and their
legs on the floor and scream and yell
and turn red or even blue.
I saw a child once who was capable of
holding his breath during a temper
tantrum until he turned blue,
which was really an impressive feat.
You should try that,
right?
It's really hard because you really have
to work at it and you see that in adult
borderlines.
They'll have temper tantrums.
And the funny thing is when a two year
old does it,
it's like it's,
you know,
it's a little off putting,
but when an adult does it,
it's completely bloody terrifying and it
happens very frequently with
borderlines.
And so I would also say to some degree,
they didn't get properly socialized
between that critical period of
development between two and four.
And you see the same thing with adult
males who grow up to be antisocial
because a large proportion of adult
males who grow up to be anti social are
aggressive as children,
as two year olds.
And so there's a small proportion of two
year olds who are quite aggressive.
They'll kick and hit and bite and steal
if you put them with other two year
olds,
it's about five percent of the of the
males,
smaller fraction of the females,
but most of them are socialized by the
time they're four,
but there's a small percentage who
aren't and they tend to stay anti social
and they tend to turn into longterm
offenders.
And and the,
the critical period for socialization
development seems to be between two and
four and it seems to be mediated by
pretend play in rough and tumble play in
those sorts of mechanisms.
And if it isn't instantiated by the age
of four,
it doesn't happen and it doesn't look
like it's addressable.
Now,
there are dialectic behavioral therapies
that have been developed for people with
borderline personality disorder and
their purported to be successful.